Alum how are you guys doing and welcome
to another podcast where I'm with a very
esteemed and very accomplished guest who
is Abdullah lusi an individual now as a
researcher for the I3 Institute and
we're here in the I3 Hub in Canada where
we've had events where we've spoken
about the Palestine issue um first of
all a quick one what do you make of the
whole issue from the you're looking at
this and your what's your assessment of
it all okay
um so the current situation in Gaza is a
continuation of a very consistent
Israeli historical policy of um of
aggression uh expansion and settlement
and so the because Israel was has always
been consistently initiating Wars
fighting uh putting using pressure
tactics by maintaining even at times of
Peace a
lowlevel uh amount of military
operations and police and security
operations
uh despite the fact they might agree to
cease fires and this always inevitably
antagonizes uh the Palestinians and
others um to to uh retaliate um or to
protest in some way or form and then
this Israel used as a pretext to advance
it its Territorial and strategic goals
further okay well well I do want to
delve a little bit into the historical
analysis with you because I know that
you've done a lot of research on that
and before I do so I just want to make
um it clear that the importance of this
is actually on the information War that
when say for example Pro Palestinian
activists Muslims and others are making
the case that they should be making a
case using solid and sound argumentation
and so what you're going to do hopefully
today is not you're not going into
elaborative detail but you're giving
them a taster of some of the historical
give the skeleton of what's happened
historically if they're interested
obviously they can go and do their own
research so let's start with u i mean
when when do you want to start when do
you think is a good time to start
historically I I think that first we
need to make a very basic AR argument
that I think Muslims need to know and
anyone who advocates for for the
Palestines needs to know which is this
the Zionist narrative is that they own
they're responding to attacks against
themselves but they never explain and
never can it be explained uh what is the
motivation of the opponents they're
claiming is that are attacking them
because they'll say oh they just hate us
or they want to wipe out um Israel's
political entity or or kill Jews or
Hamas or they'll say look uh the Hamas
is a terrorist organization they're
trying to it's all their fault but
remember they always uh kind of explain
the motivation as just this inexplicable
evil but human beings don't work like
that right human beings have um usually
make rational choices depending on how
how to achieve their objectives and
their object objectives more or less
when it comes to collectives um are what
they would deem to be reasonable or
attainable MH so if zionists arguing
that Hamas or others are just want to
wipe out all Jews from the face of the
Earth or wipe out all Jews in Israel
which is their narrative um how would
that make sense by just firing a few
Rockets or just doing um a one-way
suicid or Raid into just neighboring um
uh settlements and military bases that's
not going to destroy Israel that's not
going to harm its strategic or have no
strategic effect actually on Israel so
if that doesn't make sense which it
doesn't we have to ask further question
what's going on what's Happening that is
not so reported on the scene that is
making uh either the fat the or the
palestin Authority or Hamas or the
average Palestinian uh respond in with
anger and and being upset or even
responding um with either protests or
violence because of course before 1987
there was no Hamas and in the West Bank
there is no Hamas so um even now until
this time so going into the historical
analysis removes
Hamas essentially from the assessment
the analysis well I mean just this year
there was a major Israeli Security
operation uh that killed that killed
tens of Palestinians in the West Bank
and there was no Hamas there exactly
right so we have to ask this question as
to what's actually going on what is
Israel actually doing to the
Palestinians um which is not as report
it's not reported and it's usually a
day-to-day um just their normal
experience of life for the Palestinians
what's happened to them to make them
react with such outbursts right so tell
us some some quick facts in terms of
historical facts of people might not
even understand what is the beef going
on here I mean who are the natives to
the land of Israel um is it the
Palestinian Arabs are they the Jews is a
combination of both what's the beef
about when did it start I'm not going to
go all the way back into ancient history
here let's keep it contemporary what
would you say to this well the the
argument from the Zionist narrative is
um that the uh the ethnic group which
they represent which which they're
trying to they claim they represent they
don't represented of course many Jews uh
condemn a significant majorities condemn
um Zionism but their argument is that
Jews are not Invaders of Palestine or
then and zionists not Invaders of
Palestine because um Jews are natives of
Palestine they were there uh 2,000 years
ago they're just coming back home after
2,000 years okay so this this really is
it's a side point but they use it as a
justifying narrative so we have to
discuss it of course so if we're just
going to discuss it from a purely uh
just a historical uh analysis um the
oldest historical record which has some
coroporation um in some parts not
entirely but has some coroporation is
the the the Torah the Tanakh um the Old
Testament as Christians call it and if
you look at that and you also look at
archaeological evidence we see that the
Israelites haven't always been there um
the Israelites being the 12 tribes of
Israel Judah is One Tribe of Israel
which then was used to mean to call the
Jews Jews um they invaded the land the
the people that lived there were called
Canaanites or the land was called Canan
or Canaanites um with with the
inhabitants and they were invaded and
there was a kind of genocide of them uh
by the invading Israelite tribes as
reported in the Bible in the Old
Testament right yeah yeah so if you're
going to be historical just purely
historical um the Israelites were
Invaders of the land um approximately uh
they said they say about roughly we
historians think about 1200 BC and um
they remained in the Land There was uh
you know Wars with rival Empires and
things and they were you know moved
around and things like this um but at
some point um after 70 uh ad or so as
they say um or the commer CE y uh you
know many Jews immigrated Al They Jews
they immigrated actually before that I
mean Rome is reported to have 50,000
Jews uh at least 100 years before well
50 to 100 years before the 70 CE uh they
most economic migrants they were going
for um you know better prospects in in
Rome and so on and so forth so Jews left
for various reasons like Jews would like
people would leave for any reason you
know uh better prospects what have you
and of course you know it was it was a
land that was in in a Crossroads so
there was many walls and things it was
very unstable place to be you made a
really good point before when we did
this uh this this segment I'm not sure
if people remember but I do uh if you
want more information we've done a
reaction before on the Jordan Peterson
discussion with Netanyahu yeah yeah and
you made a very very good point which I
remember which is that if you really
count the years of let's say the Arab
majority in that area versus the Jewish
majority in that area you were saying
it's more with the Arab majority okay so
so basically why I mentioned the um the
habitation of uh Jews who would L be
called ashkanazi Jews so let's just call
it say say EUR European Jews for short
so ashkanazi Jews left that region um
before there was uh an uprising by uh
Jews against Roman occupation
and so and they were there for even
hundreds of years even after 70 CE the
zionists always cite 70 CE as the time
that Jews were kicked out without their
will and consent that that's
historically not true um there was no
Mass kicking out there was there was
further rebellions you can't have
further rebellions in a place where
there's no people to actually rise up
you know so that's not true um and there
was an expulsion though of course in 70
AD right uh no there was a capture of of
many of many Jews who were part of the
uprising and they were enslaved and sent
to Rome but there were already Jews in
Rome a significant proportion who were
just m economic migrants not slaves yeah
that that's the point and they were Jews
there there was still significant
majority of Jews residing in Palestine
afterwards now here's the thing right so
ashkanazi Jews um if you count the
amount of so if you count if you take 7c
as a basis what you'll find is that if
you count the amount of time that
Israelites have been in that land in
total so up to that points let's say
let's take 1200 12 1300 uh years yeah
and the amount of time they've been out
outside the land since 70 so let's say
for Asi Jews they came they started to
come in greater numbers in 1800s yeah so
they've been outside the land for 1,800
years and they've only ever been inside
the land in ancestrally speaking for
1300 years very interesting point so
they they were Invaders In the first
they were Invaders at the beginning yes
and they okay let's say even if we even
if we consider see they got kicked out
which they didn't yes um the majority of
them weren't kicked out but they've been
living outside the land for longer than
their their ancestors ever lived inside
the land so how are they natives then
yes CU now we have to go to what what is
native what is being na indigenous to a
land excellent so that's a really good
background let's get to the Mona now
because okay okay so so you know like
Fast Forward um so the land has had many
people in it um you know just want to
make a point that DNA studies on both
Palestinians and so on have showed that
Palestinians um have about 60 to 70% DNA
tra traced to kenites right oh
interesting yeah and because many kites
May might have converted to Judaism and
then convert to Christianity and then
convert to Islam right but they speak
Arabic so they just called Arabs you
understand because as you know an Arab
is anyone who speaks Arabic um there's
also um analysis done on Lebanese people
and it showed that they were like about
90% Canaanites really so so the people
that live in that region are more or
less their that L there for and that's
by kite up to 4,000 years ago so they
it's pretty old so now we've established
that cuz Palestines are often said that
they're just Arabs that invaded from
Arabia in the 7th Century uh no um just
because they called Arabs doesn't mean
they're they're Arabians sure yeah
they're just Arabic speakers okay um now
there were Palestinian Jews which which
resided for that time not going to you
know they and they they were called
Palestinians along with everybody else
by the British and others um okay so now
we get to kind of more um the 18th
century and so on you have uh political
zionists rise up in Europe they are
complaining about how
um Jews are treated in in Europe yeah in
Russia there's programs um there's
discrimination Western Europe there's no
programs anymore around about that time
but what year are we here so we're
talking about the 19th century the 1800s
up to the mid middle middle 1800s so
there was issues of um you know Jews are
are discriminated jewi the Jewish
problem it was called isn't it uh in in
various Western countries yeah yeah they
were because they had they were viewed
to have different Customs you know
different beliefs um and so they were
viewed to be this you know a minority
that couldn't really blend in very well
by by many races at the time um but
there was no prgrams or um massacres in
in France England not just yet
yeah well yeah of course um United
States of America Canada of course there
and in fact um you know Jews received
quite a lot of Rights in in in England
and um America and so on so forth which
either are America being a melting part
of different ethnicities or immigrants
okay so uh what happened was that there
was argument by political zionists that
the only way to solve this the problem
of um of discrimination and racism and
so on so forth is that Jews need to
control their own land right they have
to have a land and they have to be in
control of it the ones who control the
power their ethnicity not other the
ethnicities or no America you have
rights there's no pogroms against Jews
never was yeah um but that was not
really discussed right but this was an
age of nationalism so this is the time
where people like you know Theodore
Herzel and um ch and others would send
correspondences with the British Empire
asking them for land and then the
British Empire would come back and say
for example hey you got Uganda for as an
example with ch mman or Argentina with
Theodor herzo and they were like no it
has to be and these These are primary
sources which anyone can can can get
very easily and they were like no it has
to be Palestine it can't be Uganda and
it can't be Argentina U and so this is
these are kind of conversations
happening obviously this is right before
the Bel for declaration in 1917 so so to
fast forward to that now yeah yeah we've
got all this Zionist you know jargon or
let's say narrative so so so to raise
the point so basically at first um there
were different types of of zionists some
were cultural zionists they just wanted
uh a a central Hub in the world where
you can have a cultural hub for Jews um
they weren't they weren't talking about
politics they didn't really care about
politics so much so they they began
immigrating to Palestine and under
ottoman rule so Ottomans allowed Jews to
come to immigrate um into Palestine um
but but when there was caught wind of of
political Zionism as an ultimate goal
there was them some issues like well are
you coming here just to be part of the
people no problem but are you are you
coming here uh to take over the place
and become um and and make an
ethnonationalist State that's something
else that's a different discussion so so
uh Jews began immigrating into Palestine
under the ottoman under Islamic ottoman
caliphate yes um but it was only when
the British invaded and and and of of
course just prior to that Invasion where
there was an agreement between uh some
uh Rich influential uh kind of uh Jewish
uh um uh bankers and others in England
uh with of course the the F British
establishment to say look uh we can
basically uh we would like to to to
reside in that land as a as a Homeland
for ourselves as a as an ethnonational
state for Jews and the British made that
deal right so when we take it over we
will be committed to as the Baff
declaration we be committed to
establishing Jewish homeland for you the
benefits for Britain was was um it's bit
longwinded but in essence um it was
useful for them to have um those that be
willing to cooperate with them having a
strategic Outpost to control a strategic
region so Britain wanted to use uh the
zionists to be an outpost uh for British
strategic interests so we've covered the
the kind of the um the the genetic
history if you like and then we moved
into like say the 19th century we talked
about kind of very briefly and of course
this is just superficial but trying to
get the main points here for people to
have a clear timeline in their minds and
then we we're here at the bord
exploration
197 and the British man mandate for
Palestine which is effectively Britain's
control of Palestine it was called the
British mandate at that time so let's
move a little bit forward now maybe
through to the 30s and 40s right of
course before World War II um where
there was mass immigration of Jewish
people into uh the land of Palestine of
course there was lot of things that
happened there so so I mean the Bala
declaration is basically an agreement um
between Walter Rothchild um who was a
Jewish backer to to the political
Zionism and of course after ball so once
then the British um kind of finally
conquer um Palestine and with the with
the help of uh uh kind of Arabs from
Arabia from under Sharif Hussein and
others um they had initially promised to
give the land uh to Sharif Hussein there
was a an agreement you could say with
Shar husin that actually pre was was two
years before the balford Declaration
this is important because people claim
that then legally speaking the Bal
declaration is a legal document that
gives ownership to Zionist but techn
because it was in agreement with the
with the occupying power but the British
actually made a prior agreement uh to
actually give Sharif Hussein all of um
almost all of al-sham that was about
1915 right yeah 1915 so on so forth
that's just slight but um so they uh
once the British control Palestine um
they they create they create a mandate
so the Mandate of Palestine where
they're meant to be supervisors over it
and to it can become an independent
state much like they did in in different
um parts of the Muslim World cutting
into pieces making nation states but
they then start increasing migration
allowing a mass migration of um o of of
Jews from Russia who are escaping
persecution so on so forth political
zers from countries are not where there
wasn't prosecution like Brit Britain and
and and so and so for um interestingly
enough uh many Jews came to uh Palestine
and then use it as a jumping off point
to actually go to America because
America was better prospects and it was
you know promised freedom and rights so
they said why are we going to go to this
more desolate area you know and it just
that's just that has already indigenous
population who are not too happy about
British occupation why am I going to go
here why not America and there's that's
why the second most populist place in
the world where Jews reside is United
States of America only a few million
difference between the amount of Jews
that live in America and Mal that live
in in um the land of Palestine as these
people are coming in now the Jewish
people are coming into Palestine now
we're seeing a population or demographic
change and and this if you like it
really does go up exponentially in the
1930s doesn't it yeah and and then
you've got things like the Arab Revolt
which take place which is a very key
time and place which which forced the
British people to take note uh
Chamberlain for example who was the then
prime minister at the time then moved on
to like you know the white paper and
stuff maybe I think that was 1938 or
something like give us a little bit of
going what's happening here so so
basically um the the the political
zionists were initially naive IE they
didn't care about the population the
native population what they would say or
do thinking that they would just exceed
to whatever the British um give give to
the the Zionist yeah so they didn't
think there's going to be any resistance
initially right they think that or it
could be easily just dealt with so this
is very sorry sorry but this is very
important so Palestinian resistance
effectively starts in the 1930s I mean
we're talking about New Age Palestinian
resistance where there's violence and or
if you like um protest action and
there's there's an action against uh
both the Zionist groups and the British
mandate well yeah from 1936 to 39
there's basically called the Arab Revolt
uh where they they Revol against the
British uh the British occupation and
the British um kind of attempt to uh
create a an ethnonationalist state for
Jews and there was no Hamas at this time
was there there there's no
Hamas
so this is the people that there they're
not happy now now the argument initially
is that designers were coming and just
buying land and they weren't forcing
they weren't um you know forcing people
off uh but this is not exactly entirely
the the full story uh the full story is
is that um they would there would be a
kind of a one-sided Market where they
would come uh Arabs who were selling
their land because everyone's buying and
selling you have an equilibrium buying
buyers and sellers so what they do is
they they the Jewish National Fund would
be set up or certain types of of of zist
funds would be set up they would buy any
um you know land from any Arabs who were
selling and even if that through
sometimes a proxy they'd get an Arab
intermediary to buy it because many
people didn't want to sell to Zionist so
they got an AR intermediated to to buy
it then they would buy the land now the
land has people working on it right you
might have people who are um tenant
farmers who are renting and so on if
they were Arab they would they'd all be
kicked out
right cuz I'm the new landlord now is
actually the Jewish National font you're
going to be kicked out and replaced with
uh Jewish tenant Farmers yeah now
imagine someone buys a a house of flats
okay and let's say the house of flats is
in is in the part of London or what have
you where it's like 60% afroc Caribbean
let's just say right so one you they get
a new landlord and they say right then
um you know everyone who's afro
Caribbean I'm going to kick you out and
I'm going to replace you with white
people right and only white people what
would you say that's pretty racist of
yeah and you're ethnically you're not
killing or people per se but you are in
a sense ethnically
cleansing you know by other means yeah
of course so that was happening yeah and
the the Arab the cities in palestin
became filled up with uh with Arabs who
were landless because they had been
kicked out of their land uh they were
tenant farmers and they didn't know
didn't know didn't have anywhere to go
and this became a problem such that the
appeal commission was invest was um
commissioned by Britain to investigate
what to do about all these Arab tenant
Farmers what year was this pill
commission so the the pill commission I
mean kind of happens after the the Arab
revolt and the white paper is produced
which gives a solution to um the problem
that's by Chamberlain and that was at at
first very much taken badly by the
Zionist groups who after that had been
released because it wasn't as favorable
as they wanted it to be then started to
ramp up the terrorism isn't it and at
this time you had the uron and the Levi
and other groups which were effectively
Jewish terrorist groups who started to
uh act in a manner to kill
non-combatants Didn't They yeah so yeah
so 1937 pill commission um like
uncovered these these problems of um and
they they recommended that the best
solution would be maybe to partition
land and uh kind of deal with maybe sty
Mass migration because one of the issues
that the the the locals were having
problem with that all this Mass
migration was coming into their land uh
to the point with with the express
intention of creating an ethnonational
state where they would then be a
minority on their own land of course
okay so anyone who lives who's a native
of their own land wouldn't like uh the
the to to to know that basically they're
being in in essence rendered a
deliberate minority uh and they would
never achieve um kind of political
sovereignty for themselves of course
right so then okay so then the British
tried to then plate the Arabs in this to
this extent they had white papers
released and they Implement a policy to
to uh reduce migration to more
manageable Liv they don't stop it
completely but they reduce it and how
did the the two kind of major groups uh
major you could say military groups of
the Z because they actually had militant
groups or militias so the hagana and the
the hag and the the which is the main
one which would late become the Israeli
Defense Force and of course you had
theun and then you also had the the the
Le Ley and and Stern gang so these start
kicking in um Terror operations against
the British of course ha had much more
of a considered tone in this in this
whole thing they weren't as Brash and
Brazen Asun and uh lihi would you agree
with this well I mean like initially
they even worked with the British to
suppress the Arab Revolt so they were
trained they had weapons and so on and
so forth uh but then they began um doing
deliberate um uh Terror attacks against
Britain yeah to force them to resume
uh the Zionist plan which is to uh
increase Mass migration and with the
hope that eventually they can uh the
Zionist can get a Jewish majority in
Palestine uh and then create a a Jewish
ethn nationalist state where they are
the majority and probably the most
prominent example of that was 1946 King
David Hotel bombing wasn't it with 91
people that were killed civilians
including uh Brit actually there were
British civilians for the most part
there some Arabs that did die but this
was an attack on British people wasn't
it oh of course I mean uh but not just
that the uh they were um by the way Sor
ships just to cut off very interestingly
uh just like we're seeing nowadays with
the Israeli Army saying that this you
know this hospital or this hotel or this
thing is housing the terrorists they
made the same kind of argument they said
this is the headquarters for the British
Empire or the headquarters for the
British and we have to bomb it because
uh they're there and in fact they did
the same tactics with the same tactics
of warning uh the people in the hotel
that there's going to be some kind of an
attack on there and they they attack
they killed they killed the Civ they
killed the people there the
non-combatants and others in the same
way and these were white people and I
want to make it very clear that the same
tactics that the Israeli Defense Force
is employing now with Palestinian people
the Zionist uron which was their if you
like predecessor um employed with with
white English people yeah and and also
what people don't realize um because
some people say well um because the urun
and lei and so on they were pretty um
they they would be kill killing outright
uh and regardless of whether the the
media would ever at the time would would
cover it they'd be outright just um
killing um women and children palestin
Arab women and children the hag at least
attempted to try to to not appear to do
so yeah but uh when in reaction to the
the white paper the British white paper
in October 45 they actually all
officially joined forces to call
themselves The Jewish resistance
movement right so they so these hug were
totally happy to un with these people
right to fight the British and and and
there were even um kind of refugee ships
or ships that had uh kind of Jewish
refugees uh where the British tried to
kind of turn them around from Palestine
to send them to to elsewhere in
following the white paper and um the hug
bomb these these ships with with with
Jewish people on these ships sunk them
and killed Jews to make a statement the
statement was that uh you must allow uh
you know these migrants to come to the
state of Palestine don't send them
elsewhere and what's really powerful and
interesting about this is that some of
the key figures of these Jewish
terrorist groups ended up becoming Prime
Ministers and presidents of the of the
state of Israel thereafter like M mcin
for example mahay and mcin and mongan of
course was part of hag and he was the
Prime Minister of Israel and a leading
figure in the wars that Israel done with
the Arab states which we're going to
cover next well in in the history of
Israel you never see um uh any Zionist
uh terrorist who was even declared to be
terrorist uh by the British and so on so
forth um ever and were actually did
commit crime war crimes you could say
ever be prosecuted by Israeli courts you
get Nazi war war criminals being
prosecuted by Israeli courts but you
never get um former members ofun or Lei
or someone ever being prosecuted but
they did call them terrorists and that's
something we're seeing which is
different when they were killing the
white man they were happy calling Ur Le
and Stern gang terrorists and this was
very clear in the front page newspapers
of almost all the British outlets at the
time but when the same kind of operation
is done to people of a different
ethnicity they don't want to call them
terrorists because now they're they're
State and they're not killing white
people they're killing Palestinians um
do you know what's what's the irony is
that these when the hag and lei and St
and were basically Mar Mosley uh were
getting weapons and and ammunition and
the British was trying to stop this yes
so they would they would smuggle weapons
in and they would hide them in civilian
buildings um in hospitals underneath and
so on so for
they ACC they ACC Hamas of they did
exactly themselves well I mean you just
mentioned they they didn't mind uh their
own effectively Jewish people being
killed in in the ships I mean and we we
should also put point out that um these
groups and so on they also me they
always mention this this Mahi of uh of
Palestine having discussion with Hitler
but they don't mention the fact that
Theon had a pact with the Nazis which is
known in peerreview journals and they
both have the same United objective
which was to get rid of Jewish people
from Europe and bring them to Palestine
so they had a reason to unite so in many
ways the uron and the Nazis uh I mean
they did collaborate didn't they well I
mean what most people don't realize
firstly so just just to explain the
context so um uh especially Benjamin
Netanyahu he claims that the grand Muti
of Jerusalem at the time of 947 uh um
spoke with prior to 947 of course had
had met with Hitler that's true
and had Hitler wasn't really intending
to kill Jews uh in a holocaust but but
this Muti gave him the idea to do so
which there's no evidence for it's
completely ridiculous and there's
evidence to to there's well-known
evidence to show that this was the plan
that Hitler had well before before that
so he's trying to create a narrative
isn't it he's trying to create narrative
to blame the Holocaust on Palestinians
basically and the grand Muti of
Jerusalem doesn't is not the ruler of
the Palestinian the Palestinian didn't
have a central government yes of to
represent them right right the the hag
and the the um uh the well they were
called the yesu uh the those who were
these these these zionists who were
basically settling in Palestine they had
a kind of centralized kind of
semi-government system alongside the
British government that was occupying
the land the Palestinians were never
never had were never United under any
kind of uh one government or one rule or
any of this kind of stuff that that's
what led them to being so so vulnerable
uh to both the British and um the hgab
prior to establishing the state of
Israel there spoke about just to just
repeat the timeline so maybe people
taken notes on this and I do recommend
that people take notes of this that we
spoke about kind of like the 1800s the
late 1800s 19th century then we spoke
about you know the bord Declaration 1917
we spoke about then the British mandate
to govern uh all over the 1920s and then
in the 30s we we mentioned uh 1936 in
particular which is the Arab revolt and
then we mentioned the white paper which
I think is 19 the appeal report was 1937
and then you mention of course the uh
white paper which I think is 1939 nille
Chamberlain um the pm at the time in
England and then we went into the 1940s
and we discussed some of the things the
terrorist action that because of the
anger of some of these Zionist groups
including but not limited to Stan Lehi
and so so on they decided to take action
and we went all the way up to 1946 with
one of the most egregious um actions
that was taken against white people
which is the David uh King David Hotel
bombing in 19 uh 46 now we're kind of at
the precipice of the Inception of what
is referred to as the St of Israel which
which was incepted in
1948 in May the 20th so tell us what's
going on around there so let's start now
let's start from when um the UN
resolution in November 1947 is is
adopted to recommend partition of course
so partition now the Zionist would claim
that well the Arabs didn't accept it and
but we were we accepted it so um but
because they didn't accept it it's not
binding on us um first first and
foremost they they had no intention of
honoring any part partition so um Ben
gurin himself mentions yeah that uh they
would initially they would initially um
Ben Goran who is he oh sorry yes sorry
so Ben grian would like later on become
the leader well he is he at this point
he's he's um he's the leader of the the
kind of the Jewish government um prior
to the establishment of state of Israel
and then he becomes the leader of hag
right oh well he he's the commander of
it obviously and then he became the PM
of the yeah he became the prime minister
of just for the people to there's it's a
semi-presidential system in Israel so
they have a president and a prime
minister at the same time yes yeah and
the Prime Minister has more power than
the president yeah cuz the president is
just basically like a figurehead um for
ceremonies and symbolic so so Ben gurian
um uh then kind of relates uh in uh we
see these discussions uh of meetings he
had with his with his cabinet and all
the people um so we see him discussing
that basically the partition was just a
stepping stone yes uh so they initially
uh okay the partition will happen right
that means that that allows them to
create a state in the partition the
Jewish partition areas what is a
partition just people don't know what
this word so the partition was the
initial un plan was to partition um uh
Palestine into two areas which are which
roughly approximates to allowing the
full the West Bank to Palestinians and
Raza to the Palestinians and uh Jews to
kind of uh uh be uh partitioned to have
the majority settlements and cities uh
through most most Parts prior to n the
1967 borders but not exactly not exactly
like that cuz the north was still for
Arabs um like yafa and so on and so
forth okay so uh then what happens I
mean the the proposal was more land than
is currently given of course to uh
Palestinians now in terms of territories
I mean the the initial partition had
more land that was proposed to the
Palestinians than is for example now
under the or Hamas and all the uh
Palestinian Authority um it was much
more land it was much more land uh but
then benur kind of admitted um in in
his plan and uh for for what they would
do after the partition has been accepted
yes is that they would they would then
um demand from the from the Arab
Palestinians that Jews should be allowed
to settle uh in in significant
majorities to make a majority uh in like
the negative and trans Jordan he me you
mentioned this negtive and trans Jordan
and that if the if the AR inian say look
um we look uh we we we don't want to be
a minority in our own land um and so we
don't accept that we don't won't accept
any deals any Financial inducements or
anything like this then they said
they're prepared to use Force yeah to
until they can settle and on the entire
land of Palestine are we now before or
after the establishment of the CATE of
Israel are we have we established the
this is just prior to sure yeah U so
this is showing about Communications
benan was like let's only going to
accept the partition yes um just so that
people um give us the space to create a
a formal State military apparatus a
state once we have that we're not going
to stop at the partition so someone will
say okay that's a that's a pretty tall
claim what's the source for this have
you got any information any Source
academic citations yes yes yes I um I
have the evidence right here um so um
Ben gurin kind of um uh clearly admits
that in in a meeting with the the Jewish
agency executive the Jewish agency was
the the government you could say um of
the uh of the zionists in Palestine so
it's in in June 1938 uh in a in a
meeting minutes he argued that he talks
about um uh where someone says to him
you know uh shall we uh shall we like
expand our population and transfer the
Arabs out of uh Palestine by force so he
says that initially wants to do by says
mutual agreement with them uh when
they'll see that they can't stand up to
us when they see we give Financial
incentives but here's the thing he says
so let us assume that the negtive for
example which is um currently uh under
occupation by Israel of course in in the
internationally recognized borders quote
unquote uh so he says let us assume
assume that the negative will not be
included in the Jewish state it would
then remain Barren the Arabs are not
capable or of or or no need to develop
and build it they have their fair share
of deserts and they lack the human
resources the money and the initiative
this was typical colonialist mentality
looking at these natives they won't
develop it like we would and it's very
likely that in exchange for our
financial military and organizational
scientific assistance the Arabs will
agree that we develop and build the
negative it is also possible they will
not agree uh people does not be always
behave according to logic common sense
and best interest so they think well
these natives don't see that that us we
that kind of giving it to us or allowing
us to develop it is in their best
interest uh then and here's now comes
what the the alternative is um so so
just like so he's talking to this guy
called Amos just like you I feel a
contradiction between your mind and your
heart so it's possible that Arabs will
act according to sterile National
nationalist emotion and will tell us we
want neither your honey nor your sting
it is better for the negative to remain
Barren than to be populated by you and
then he says and then we will have to
talk to them in a different language and
we will have a different language which
we will not have unless we have a state
because we cannot stand to see such
large areas of unsettled land capable of
absorbing dozens of thousands of Jews
remain
empty uh so this is what he he says and
then he says and then we will have to
use force and we will use it without
hesitation uh though we only if we have
no other choice we we do not wish and do
not need to expel Arabs and take their
place our aspiration is built on the
Assumption proven throughout our
activity there's enough room in our in
the country for both ourselves and the
Arabs but we will have to use but if we
have to use Force um to guarantee our
own right to settle in those places then
we have Force at our disposal so here
was his point was that they first going
to accept the partition to establish
their state when they have the state
they have an army now they have an army
uh they can they can now give the Arabs
a choice they say now you let us settle
and build settlements on the Arab
partition areas and take those lands and
you can be with us and you can benefit
from the finances and so on so forth we
won't we don't want to kick you out
initially as long as you allow Mass
migration but if you don't then we're
going to take those lands by force and
um and uh but not primarily to expel
they said initi not primarily to expel
the Arabs uh but so that they can settle
any everywhere throughout the land of
pales I mean there are more explicit of
course uh statements like for example
beIN MIM I can't pronounce his first
name but beIN who be who became a
president of the of the state of Israel
he had a book called Revolt the revolt
and in it he's very very clear about
expelling with Force killing the people
in The Villages the hate he has for the
Palestinians this is something you can
get online you can get a PDF copy of
this particular book um of course when
the state of Israel was established um
you had uh formal you know legal things
which you can you can find like for
example plet and of course plet was I
mean I'm let me ask you what what is
plal for those who don't know and tell
us now the exception of say of Israel
and then the subsequent neba that
happened what what's going on with that
what is planal okay so so then uh so Ben
grin first thought that once he you have
a partition and uh and zionists can then
have a state and the state can have an
army and then they can in essence um
diplomatically first try to make an
agreement to take over the remaining
part of Palestine but if the palestin
Arabs don't agree to that then by force
so they're always going to take it over
yeah however um because in 1947 uh
because then the um the Palestinians
basically U you know they were not going
to accept this uh what happened was they
used the pretext so they said okay um
since the there the partition has been
declared and since then there is um we
need to have an the Arabic you know
states are not accepting this the
Palestines are not accepting this uh you
know we need to we need to kind of get
reinforce our state as much as possible
make it stronger as quickly as possible
uh we need to make to take strategic
land quote unquote uh and so they
accelerated their plans to take over the
Arab partitions so in essence they
launched a war um in 1947
uh beginning in December 1947 ending in
March 1948 uh went to do clearing
operations and there was a plan called
plan dalit which was a plan that was
given to all military commanders of the
Hagar that they would go to um Arab
Villages and towns which are in
strategic areas quote unquote which is
basically um most of of Palestine uh and
they would um they would assess the town
if the town uh is in a strategic area
they would basically clear out the
population all right uh through any
means right generally but uh there there
was unofficial communic Cas things that
are not recorded in such official plans
uh where in essence the the Hagar
leaders understood that if the state of
if Palestine was to be made um a state
uh one whole state like not separated
but every everyone being equal citizens
the Arabs already had a majority still
they were still a majority of of that
land and even in the in the Jewish
partition areas um that was given to
zionists um there was still a
significant proportion there was 40%
Arabs so the first thing they were going
to do is they're going to clear out
they're going to change that demographic
Ben gurian even cited that how can we
have a Jewish State even with only 60
60% Jews even there're still the
majority but it's the the the the Arab
minority is still too big right so this
led to basically uh they called clearing
operations they would go uh either
they'd give an ultimatum or they would
uh if there was any resistance
encountered from any Arab Village
encountered or town encountered uh they
were given full reain to to just go in
guns blazing literally um and uh and
wipe him out if possible and obviously a
good book for this is ilam pape's ethnic
cleansing of Palestine it's one of the
staple books that want someone wants
more information on that let's go
forward because I think a lot of the you
know the Israeli and Zionist historians
make it out as if okay now you got the
establish what it is is you got the UN
who have put this this uh partition plan
has been accepted you got the
establishment of the state of Israel and
then you had all this antagonism you had
all this provocation you had all these
attacks starting with 1948 with all
these Arab states attacking Israel
Israel have always been defending
themselves of course what we've already
shown right here is that everything's
been
aggressive so so how would you defend
yourself against something like that
1948 the Arab states came and attacked
Israel so as I said so the the UN
partition plan was never respected by
the zionists um like before they even
established a state right so this is
again in 47 they launched attacks to
take to do land grabs in areas that was
meant to be a portion to the
Palestinians it now this is this is this
is without the involvement of the Arab
armies around without the involvement in
the Arab states the Arab the pisans
didn't have a a formal Army of any kind
they didn't have a centralized Command
right in many cases each Village had its
own separate militia
right there was no initiation of an
invasion or even a land grabbed by
Palestinians into the Jewish apportion
area or the zist a portioned areas that
didn't exist okay it was the only people
that had an army and a centralized
command were was the the the Zionist um
kind of settlement settlers there under
the hag yes the the Jewish agency as it
was called they're the ones that had a
centralized government I see so they
they could launch offensive operations
and they did into the areas that were me
to be Arab partition land and they made
the excuse well the Arabs aren't
accepting the partition mhm yeah but
they're not they're not invading the
Jewish partition area so to speak that
was given to Zionist so uh but they just
said well you know they're not accepting
it and so they started to invade that
was that you could say the initiation of
um an aggression other than from the
British Invasion you could say this was
where the Jewish agency which would then
become the Israeli State or the
government uh was the initiate of
invasions of in actually itself invading
and taking land right so we've got 1948
and then you've got the 47 till March to
March 48 this already kicks out 100,000
Palestinians out out of their lands
right so tell us about the nakba what is
the nakba now okay well technically
speaking this is the beginning of the
nakba right which is the great
catastrophe disaster where Palestinians
are ethnically cleansed from the from
towns and cities and so on so forth um
and then we have uh then we have the
kind of the uh declaration of the state
of Israel on the 15th of May
1948 now this is where um you know like
planned dialect was already formulated
by this time to clear out it wasn't in a
response to the Arab armies coming in
the Arab armies it wasn't response
Palestines weren weren't uh uh streaming
out of that's a good that's a good point
because they could say well that that
was Plan D it was a response to the Arab
invasions which would be historically
correct was planet was was even before
the Declaration of the state of Israel
as as an independent State and the Arab
Army's response and the and so on so
forth so um so they so they declare uh
so the day before the end of the British
mandate on the 15th of May on the 14th
of May Day Before Ben gurin and the the
Jewish agency estab declare the
establishment of a Jewish State um now
the Arab states protest against the um
the separation of Palestine into
partition to you and they submit a
formal letter and what their letter
offers
is that they say look don't cut into
pieces make it all one state okay they
didn't talk about saying we must kick
out Jews no no no no they said one state
everyone is becomes a citizen and
minority rights are protected under a
democratic State that's what they
offered right which means that well
there were Jews living there of course
after the migration but they were still
a minority right but the the Arab states
said look look let's not create
ethnonational States you know uh the the
man the British man is about to end is
going to end so let's just make a a one
state solution everyone equal citizens
how about that yeah of course the UN
didn't accept that of course and of
course the the Zionist would never
accept that because their whole point of
their existence is to create an ethnon
naist state that whereby Jews are a
majority in a democratic State and
therefore by de facto uh their
ethnocultural group determines the the
the the laws the nature of the state and
so on and so forth right I I say
ethnocultural group uh because they've
always had this very specific Vision
even when they they established this law
called The Law of return you know uh
where they would allow Jew anyone who
claims Jewish ancestry to come and to
return back to the land of their
ancestors right in that law and I ask
everybody to read it because people
don't read that law okay um yeah if you
if you can claim Jewish ancestry uh
significant Jewish ancestry so your
mother is is Jewish for example you can
then claim the right of return uh you
you can be Jewish you can be
atheist because Ben grian was atheist
they were socialists as well the the the
political zionists weren't religious
yeah they didn't believe in God didn't
didn't care about that stuff but if you
are a Jew with ethnically Jewish with a
mother who's Jewish but you become a
Muslim or you become a Christian you're
not given the right of return to so this
shows you that the Zionist um uh kind of
uh uh goal wasn't just to return people
who had an ancestry back to the land
yeah they don't they certainly don't
care about Palestinians they're not
included in that it's an ethn cultural
group must predominate so racist a
parttime g uh racist and even uh
religious discrimin because you
discriminatory because you could be
ethnically Jewish but be a Christian and
Muslim and you don't get to the right of
return to go back that anyway so that
that's a point what's happening tell us
about that because so so then um do you
have all these Palestinians screaming
out of Palestine you have uh you have
massacres occurring against Villages
that get widely publicized um uh you
have mass like deren and others which uh
where women children were blatantly uh
killed this is no no one denies that uh
and just shot and or grenades were
chucked into people's houses so the the
Arab regimes around and and certainly
their populations are very angry about
what's happening right so the Arab
regimes um are pressured by their people
and they make a complaint the Arab
League makes a complaint to the UN
saying that you have to stop this this
is like you like you're seeing a
massacre of Palestinians happening right
now we we're not they haven't even gone
in yet they haven't even no entry
nothing like this right so then in
response to that they say right well uh
they they gave that official letter to
un saying that uh establish a unitary
state where everyone has equal
citizenship and uh if you're not going
to do that then we going to do that yeah
they don't want to kick out all the Jews
they didn't say that they said no no eth
no national state one unitary state
everyone's equal citizen and we have to
rescue those who are being ethnically
cleansed in that land so that's was the
pretext by which they said that we we
need to go and intervene and that was
that was after all these refugees are
banging on their door yes trying to come
into their land like please help and
save us and and what have you it wasn't
they were saying no don't worry uh leave
first and then we will uh come in
whatever didn't exist or these claims
that there was radio broadcast that
people that was telling the Palestines
to leave their lands and so on um is is
is was was false yeah so now after this
you've got a series of wars that take
place yes we can't go into each of them
in great detail we've got the SE 1956 SE
Canal Crisis yes not really a war more
maybe I don't know how maybe it is a war
well I mean I mean look like like like
this it's quite we go this very quickly
which is basically yeah that um you know
the Arab states sent only a token amount
of army they actually were outnumbered
by the Zionist are you talking about
1956 here no I'm talking about the the
1948 War when they come in okay um a
further 600,000 Palestinians are made
refugees yes after they kicked out um
there are cities which were which even
benan ordered themselves to be
depopulated like you must you must leave
yeah uh I'll give you an interesting
story in in Bethlehem Bethlehem as they
say um the uh when the the Zionist
forces were were reaching there they
were going to do the same thing they
were going to do any everywhere else to
clear it out benan personally intervened
to say oh wait wait wait wait guys uh we
we have the the the records of this no
one denies say this he says no not that
it's a majority Christian town and the
eyes of the world the the superpowers
are mostly Christian they're going to
react very negatively if we if we kick
out people out of Bethlehem right so in
that they personally intervene which
shows that benur knew what a lot of his
hak commands were doing anyway because
we know because he he'd intervened
specifically tell him not to do it you
know when when to make make it the
exception so this shows you that they
had a infite cleansing policy back then
yes all right so um now4 the Arab armies
failed to to uh to uh to create a a
unitary state in Palestine and that the
state of Israel is created uh they were
outnumbered throughout the whole War the
Arab armies they were IL equipped um to
to take on that they were outnumbered by
their enemy which is ridiculous why
would you send all these armies when
only regimes would only send a minority
amount of soldiers who were outnumbered
by the enemy shows that they weren't
really interested yeah they were just
making a token gesture to Plate their
population but it's different discussion
okay so then um so then fast forward
then uh so the Israeli state is
established but it doesn't control the
West Bank it doesn't control Gaza the
Gaz under control of Egypt the West Bank
is under control of Jordan right so then
um in 1956 as you as you know uh the you
know the Egyptian regime wants wants to
nationalize the swest canal swest canal
is was was kind of kind of co-owned by
British and French interests um the the
Egypt said look this is on our territory
uh we want to nationalize it for the the
interest of the Egyptian people state it
shouldn't be owned by foreign powers
okay so then Britain in cahoots with
France and Cahoots with Israel
coordinate a invasion of the sin and the
Takeover of the of the S okay uh there
was no provocation against Israel what's
Israel going to do with this yeah but um
this shows that Israel's main function
has always been to to further the
Strategic interests of the West its
relationship with the West is that it
fulfills its strategic interest in the
Middle East it's a it's a launch pad
well I mean this this is the time where
a lot of historians say that there was a
shift in terms of superpower St of
course is after World War II yes and
when America intervened it's effectively
telling the other guys that look why
didn't you get why didn't you get me
involved in this and kind of put them
aside and and that's how the situation
was maybe resolved many historians would
say this is when really the United
States of America solidified its status
as the world superpower yeah I I mean
also I mean I mean this is when now
America starts to take over from Britain
right so Britain uses its it's your pet
project and it becomes now under you
know it makes a deal with America it
found it found a better a better sugar
daddy you could say yeah for it yeah and
so this is this is the relationship
between Israel and America but this
shows you I this is the the thesis that
you're putting forward that there was I
mean effectively you can't make the
argument that Israel is defending itself
here because they're incahoots with two
other major powers of the world ex
Empires and the biggest empires in the
world to interfere in the internal
affairs of another country of a
neighboring country which had which was
nothing to do with anything that
threaten Israel absolutely so then then
you've got something which is very well
known which is the sixth day war
otherwise known as 1967 war yeah so then
um now like Fast Forward of course
people can research these things in
their own time we're giving them a bit
of a you know we went for from the 1800s
now in 1967 so we're giving them a
superficial a skeletal if you like
timeline so they can do their own
reading but it's very important for
people to know at least the timeline
right so so yeah like almost a decade
later um so basically the um uh so is
Israel is is uh obviously not just doing
nothing right uh there is having clashes
with uh it neighboring countries but not
just clashes in the sense of like they
just fight Army to Army because because
Jordan's not fighting Israel Syria is
not fighting Israel Egypt's not fighting
Israel Lebanon Army is not fighting
Israel uh Israel is launching raids into
um uh Jordan uh into uh Egypt but Jordan
quite a lot uh destroying Jordanian
Villages like the village of Samu for
example um and uh and actually
destroying the village not just going in
to to fight but they're actually
destroying the whole village they're
claiming that this is a retaliation
against Palestinian militants now the
issue is this that um what most people
don't realize is that there was UN
observers the UN observers of the time
said that we've we there was no known
activity for uh from uh the Jordanian
controlled West Bank by Palestinian
militants secondly Jordan itself was
trying to maintain the Peace by fighting
the Palestinian militants itself and
they actually killed more Palestinian
militants than Israel had right it was
it was any if it detected any would it
would it would destroy them right so
clearly Jordan was was clearly Jordan
had was was basically suppressing um any
potential or any um militant quote
unquote militant activity by by
Palestinian argued of course someone can
say well on the on the flip side you got
gab ABD nasar in Egypt and he was very
fiery and in his anti-israel opposition
and the 1967 war was nothing but a
preemptive strike uh that attacked the
artillery of a nation which was hostile
towards uh Israel couldn't someone make
this point well you see um here's the
here's the issue right yes um so uh
Israel is attacking uh uh you know the
West Bank already all right under
Jordanian control in 19 66 one year
before the 1967 war and they are
massacring whole village and and
Villages attacking bombing constant
raids yeah so Jordan complains to the UN
saying like do something about this
because this is like really horrific
what they're doing right Jordan didn't
even react militarily right it because
it doesn't want to provoke Israel
because it knows Israel's just waiting
right just waiting it wants to provoke
Jordan uh then it because it because the
zers have a permanent interest the whole
land of Palestine as Ben gurin kind of
admitted many years ago the whole land
of Palestine is their target they want
to take all of it right they don't care
about partitions are just a starting off
point yeah but Jordan knows this okay
doesn't want to uh antagonize yeah but
the Arabs the world are angry look you
know Israel's massacring whole uh Arab
Villages what you know what to do so the
Naas is under pressure yeah because he's
viewed as you know as as the leader of
the United Arab Republic which is you
know an alliance between you know Iraq
and Syria and Egypt to become a kind of
one state kind of but they're still
separate in a way um so he's under his
pressure so he kind of he rattles Sabers
he says like don't do this and so he
closes The Straits of tyan if you if you
see that in the Sinai it's just it's on
the on the uh east side of of Sinai
there's the there's the Straits of Tyran
that leads to to the south of Israel the
South tip of Israel um the Israeli State
and he he closes it off as a gesture and
he and he moves some army forces next to
the border of um Israel to say like like
you know don't do this and then of
course America comes in swoops in other
ways say okay I'm going to deescalate
we're going to negotiate with NASA
there's good possibility that he will
open it up with negotiations he's made
his point so on so forth and of course
there is there is cumul the case by
mosad by um the the the Israeli defense
minister of the time by American
intention agencies that NASA doesn't
actually want any war with with Israel
because any fight with Israel because
the 1956 War showed them that they they
might they would most likely lose such a
war one-on-one so but they but they they
they couldn't let the massacre of Arab
Villages go so they were going to do a
show of strength yeah but there was no
it wasn't an invasion Army coming there
was it was the Army was too small to
invade you you have to have mobilization
of your population Mass mization frankly
one can say even if they did want to
invade after all that's been done it
would have been totally justified I mean
yes but the Zionist argument was that
they were they were existentially
threatened by Egypt yes at this point
even though all their communic all the
the mosad all the intelligent agencies
and their own defense minister um
admitted afterwards in their well in
their Memoirs but we also have the the
um classified cables that they said that
NASA is not intending to fight NASA
doesn't want to fight can one argue that
well why did NASA go to the Soviet Union
and um get armed by you Czechoslovakia
at the time they were arming them they
had new military hardware and so on if
they didn't really want to fight why
they why are they doing all these things
well I mean Israel s was was getting
weapons by Checkers of Vue too you know
they're buying weapons they're buying
arms to because 1956 War showed them
that Israel could Israel took siai like
that with the help of British if you're
Egypt and these PE people can just wal
into your country at will you're going
to want to defend yourself you're going
to want to arm up but but that was never
argued that was was the existential
threat right but then here's the thing
and this what Illustrated that what
happened next was Israel's own
initiation was Israel said okay they did
a a preemptive strike on on Egypt but
they took the Egyptian Army completely
by surprise exactly yeah so if if there
was this is this is a great argument
because if they were under existential
threat and the Egyptians were trying to
attack the Israelis then how could it be
a surprise that the Israelis hit them
first it's like look imagine I'm angry
at you I say I'm angry at you I'm going
to beat you up and I come at you fist
clenched you know you've seen me
limbering up you
I'm going you I'm going very angry you
and youch me the face yes why' you punch
me in the face yeah how could it be a
surprise it wouldn't be why would it be
a surprise if I'm ready to face you how
are you punching me going to surprise me
cuz I mean the way in which all these
you know these um air airplanes and
stuff like were destroyed in 6 days it
you cannot argue that this was done it
wasn't even EGP it was Syrian airfields
it was Jordanian airfields there was an
Iraqi Airfield that was just next to the
Jordan border that got obliterated too
even the Iraqis got obliterated it's
consensus even on those on the Z side I
mean they they they'll gloat and Bast
the the fact that was a surprise so sure
now now so so then what what what Israel
did is now because of that they they
taking the pen they took the Sinai
Peninsula a second time and they wanted
to hold on to it they took Gaza they
took the sign Peninsula but now they
then they used that as a penin for those
who don't know is a massive Mass massive
of land yeah yeah it's a few times
bigger than Israel the Israeli States
own controll imagine now they're taking
new land yeah yeah you know which is
illegal under international law yeah and
because now now Jordan was under a
defense Packa with Egypt and Egypt's
being invaded right so Jordan basically
just fires a few artillery shots into
into Israel to say like like to make at
least a gesture that it's honoring its
defense pact with coming to Egypt's help
yeah cuz EGP Egypt is actually being
invaded at this point yeah of course and
then Israel goes ah now we got what we
wanted so then they invade the West Bank
yes oh now you're shooting us now we've
got it now we got what we wanted a
pretext and they they and they had a
pre-prepared plan to invade the West
Bank so that's F forward now there's a
lot of anti-israel so this is how Israel
Justified its Invasion it also invaded
the the Golan even though um Syria has
um had announced a ceasefire it's not
stop it's stopping it operations it
didn't want to fight it declared it
didn't want to fight and they said no
we're going to take the Golan as well
the Golan Heights as well so now at this
point you know when does the pl come
into play the the Palestinian Liberation
Organization otherwise known as fat when
when does that
initiate okay so um this really I mean
this this this kind of stuff really
occurs um uh really towards uh the uh
the end of of the um kind of Jordanian
control of the West Bank now cuz you
have a whole bunch of Palestinians now
now are now under occupation by um the
Israelis so what year are we talking
here like so I mean this this this
begins after 1967 war this is when um a
whole bunch of these are people who had
already left their homes they they still
remember the nbar so this is 20 years
before the establishment of Hamas oh I'm
only I'm only keep I'm only repeating
this point because people are going to
scape go Hamas but Hamas didn't even
exist at this time yes so um when
Israeli attacks start start you know
attacking Palestinians and wiping out
Palestinian villagers uh even before the
1967 war um you know the Palestinians
are are all trying to organize a a
resistance against this this happens in
1964 okay the PLO is established in 1964
to be both a political
organization uh to um for Palestinian
rights yeah right and and they're
Nationalist and secular just to be clear
right yes yeah yeah they're not they're
not based on any motivated by any
religious considerations they have
mixture of Christian Arabs as you know
10% of Palestines are Christian yeah so
um so in this actually they even get
recognized to some extent by the UN in
1974 as uh having Observer status so
they get recognized as a national
movement um by the UN now the the issue
is that they uh they became political
party in 1965 andless is a political
party yeah uh to get
you know Palestinian nationhood right
for themselves a separate State uh but
once Israel occupies the West Bank and
Gaza and you have a whole bunch of
Palestinian refugees did you know that
more refugees were created now they they
were kicked out and pushed pushed more
eastwards in the West Bank so they were
already people that had were refugees 20
years ago and they were pushed even
further away or kicked out to or they
left or they were forced out and went to
Jordan other places like this Jordan
became so overcrowded with Palestinians
it would seem like about 50% of the
Jordanian population itself was
Palestinian at one point right so um
they they uh begin uh resistance and
Insurgent operations against the against
Israel because they are now under direct
occupation right before they were under
Jordanian control where at least with
the jordanians they weren't getting uh
racial discrimination they weren't
facing racial discrimination racial
harassment or so on so forth but but
under Israeli control that's when that
begins and that's when the Insurgency uh
occurs so this is where then
Palestinians are facing facing that the
zist would say what about the 1973 War
wasn't that a war that was for our
survival uh we were extensionally um
threatened uh but again that was
reclaiming sin wasn't it that was that
was yes it's false the Egyptian Army uh
wanted to reclaim s afterwards they
argued that they they had to regain the
National Honor because this was a big
slap to their face that they lost to
sign absolutely I think there there was
there was a lot of like anti-israel
sentiment at this time the Egyptian
population was absolutely outraged about
what happened yeah g ABD Nas came out in
1967 and he basically apologize to the
public he was talking about reclaiming
siai and stuff like that you know it
built up all the way up to the 1970 when
G died obviously Arad at that time had
taken power and and it was his thought
and he started negotiating with the
Americans with kissing and so on and
what what is narrated by primary sources
is that he effectively said to him we
can't do anything to you or for you
unless this becomes a crisis in the
Middle East which means that you
effectively need to have some something
to negotiate with with that an Sadat and
others decided to go into Sinai and not
take the whole thing over just a portion
of it so that they can have something go
to negotiation with Syria um in um
invades quote unquote their own land the
the um the Golan yeah they they want
that back and Egypt just invades Sinai
which was their land they they have very
limited objectives they only want to
take that those areas of land right and
even then I mean even in that war the
Israelis actually penetrated Egypt
itself I mean arel shiron he went into
what Mal went all the way up you know so
it wasn't it wasn't some passive War yes
I mean most would say that especially in
the Egyptian context that Egypt got
wanted in terms of you know objectives
of war and got the sign Peninsula back
but now we're talking about Camp David
and so we move on in in 1978
yeah so now there's this Camp David
agreement yeah so um all right so so you
know Israel was never ever really exti
threatened since 1948 ever and um any of
all the things that it does is never
because it's existentially threatened
it's because either it there's an
opportunity to expand more land um or it
to suppress anyone that um is is
identifies as a resistance to it even if
they're not actively fighting with them
at that point in time yeah so I mean
Israel regularly um flies Jets into
Syria and bombs Hezbollah targets no one
ever talks about this right Hezbollah is
not currently fighting um you know uh
the state of Israel quote unquote right
they're not in active War since since
the Lebanon war the more recent one but
they bombit regularly they say this was
Hezbollah shipment of Arms from um the
Iranian re revolutionary guards in Syria
okay well what Syria does in its own
territory on your business right uh but
they they say well this this is giving
arms to a group that we don't like well
but the group you don't like you're in a
ceasefire with them you're in you're not
you're not actively fighting with them
but you're still bombing them and that
really shows Israel's policy is that say
if we don't like you they say we're just
going to keep bombing you whe the
difference between active War and Peace
time is just the level of military
operations that Israel does against you
sure that the only difference let's get
to this point of so we' because we want
to kind of maybe wrap up now this is
there's a lot we've spoken about in
terms of the history and there's a lot
that people have that can take as like I
say it's a sceletal historical timeline
we've started from the 1800s and we're
all the way here in 19 let's say 80 now
I think cam David was 198
1978 if I'm corre correct in that the
agreement between the Egyptians and the
the Israelis and then you have SI given
back in exchange for uh peace
Everlasting peace with Egypt and and
Israel so this takes place then you have
from 1978 effective that let's just say
you've got the the peace that you wanted
with the big countries around you all
the way up to let's say 2023 which is
our year now and of course uh fat have
you know the Oslo Accords and these
attempts to try and Forge peace uh
through negotiation and so on all of
that uh as we've we've heard from
Palestinian Liberation Organization
Representatives has not been fruitful
and the Palestinians are becoming more
and more angry about this and then 1987
you have the establishment of Hamas and
so tell us now from the establishment of
Hamas until this time what are the
notable things that we should know maybe
the inter fathers some of those things
right I mean well like okay so so
basically um you know Israel doesn't
just do nothing right uh it if you look
at the history it's it's invaded its
neighbors multiple times since yeah so
it's invaded Lebanon three times yeah uh
everyone forgets that you know Lebanon
doesn't have an army to conquer anything
but because there's PL organizations
there uh and then later on the last one
there was Hezbollah they basically
invaded and they invaded again usually
as a response to a retaliation to their
own low-level military operations cuz
once they say don't they don't like you
they're going to um they either do
lowlevel attacks against you or high
level attacks against you so in when in
peace time quote unquote they just do
they maintain this constant background
hum of of assassinations bombing
targeted strikes uh Commander raids this
is what they call Peace yeah or
ceasefire and so when people say I'm
sick look I I don't like your ceasefire
cuz your ceasefire is killing us
literally uh we're going to protest by
shooting a few rockets that are not
going to re really strategically do
anything per se and then is goes at
pretext then raise up to high level
military things to they say let's see if
we can destroy this whole organization
or or TR change the Strategic balance of
Lebanon so this is basically what they
they did um like now Hamas
Rises up in the midst as in the issue of
the Lebanon war and is actually
encouraged by
Israel so so basically the Lebanon
Lebanon war starts at
1982 and um it was initially uh targeted
at that clearing out um the the the PLO
from Palestine but they commit many
outrages Israelis and they use local
nationalist Christian forces uh to to
fight so um they the Hamas was found in
1987 and it is you know it it as a
response to the Israeli occupation of of
Lebanon which was which was ongoing at
this point in time and and it was
originally funded by the Israeli I think
at one point wasn't it uh well Israel
kind of gave uh secretly gave support to
it as a rival to Fat because fat was
secular yeah PL by the way yeah and and
so Hamas is is is it's more religious in
orientation quote unquote uh it was
deemed to be a rival to weaken the PLO
yes yeah by creating a by supporting a
rival organization which would then
later on it just they lose control of of
course because it would then get its own
support now Hamas is actually meant to
be a political organization it's its
military Wing the one that actually does
the fighting is called the
isan brigades yeah and they were
actually formed in 198 1993 see yeah so
that's already 5 years after Hamas was
formed soas is a political party and
five years later it forms has a a
military Wing that does the actual uh
Insurgency and fighting so this is this
is where this happens now obviously see
um then you have the interf fathers and
so on yeah so so um meanwhile in Israel
and in the West Bank occupied
territories um you know Palestinians are
under military rule so they don't elect
governments they don't not represented
by any governments they don't have their
own leaders that uh can can uh uh
approve building permits so they can
they can house their own children in the
Next Generation that stuff they are
stifled and restricted and face police
harassment brutality uh killing
um on slightest uh pretexts and so on so
forth so uh in 1988 to
1993 they initiate the first in from the
Arabic were to kind of shake off they
wanted to shake off the occupation um it
leads to uh
1,962 Palestinians dead 270 Israelis uh
dead um due to the OCC the occupation of
West Bank and Gaza that's the key issue
Israel could have simply returned the
1967 um uh kind of borders and not give
it back to Egypt or to uh to Jordan uh
but just give it to the Palestinians who
are too weak to make in the Army and we
never threaten them ever but they don't
want to give it back and the question is
why not Jordan already relinquished the
West Bank says I don't want to have
anything to do with it any anymore if
any uh anything that happens with the
West Bank will be between you and the
Palestinians that was what it said to
Israel basically and there are two iners
right so this is the first one that you
mentioned yes when was the second one
okay so so we have uh you know we have
then the oso cuse that happens at 19 93
um which starts to talk about giving
zones of control um to the Palestinians
then you have Oslo to the the taba
agreement um that happens in
1995 which talks about areas of
disengagement so they tried to um uh
kind of uh so Israel makes this
agreement with the Palestinians and the
Palestinians this is the espe P the Y
arat it's very they're very naive on
this but they're quite desperate and
this is like this which is we're going
to split the West Bank into three zones
Zone A B and C Zone a the Palestinians
will control the security of it and the
laws and the rules and regulation
Administration um Zone B uh the
Palestine Authority uh which will be set
up by p b the P becomes the palestin
authority will control um the
administrative and laws but they don't
control the security of it so basically
person government but Israeli police
right basically and Zone C which is 60%
is controlled both by U military rule
yes and by the the Israeli Security
Forces so the Palestinians go are
offered a few areas of the West Bank
where they can actually control their
own destiny so they jump at it because
they never been offer that before uh but
it's a trap because it then justifies it
has a signature of a palestini authority
to the Israeli control of the vast
majority of the West Bank the area C
which is 60% and of course area B where
where they control the military uh and
the security operations of that so the
Palestinians have it was kind of a trap
because they've actually signed their
own occupation they've actually given
consent you could quote unquote to their
own simp point is that you don't have
them you're not allow the military there
is you're not the pales are not allow
the military but the the the the Oslo
Accords were not meant to be a permanent
thing it was meant to be phases of
disengagement yes so Israel would say
Okay area a is yours but eventually once
things are calmed down we see that it's
all working then we'll give you area
we'll give you full control of area B
and then eventually we'll see about area
C it was meant to be zones of
disengagement yeah but they could use
any pretext to stall it and say oh
there's you know one person state of
emergency yeah um one Palestinians guy's
dog bit an Israeli soldier or looked at
the soldier funny this means there's
still insecurity this means we can't
disengage International Jim Crow laws
really isn't it yeah yeah and and it
allowed them to control um the the the
the Palestinian life in the West Bank um
and and in in razza right so let's let's
move forward now to so second in Father
occurs um you know year 2000 there's a
second Uprising because seeing there the
failure of of the Israel to St stick to
its word to disengage yes and give back
land in the West Bank to the
Palestinians as it promised in stages so
this happens between year 2000 and year
2005 America commissions the Mitchell
report to see how they could uh how they
could stop the interfa um how people you
know di on that one um uh well in 3,000
dead Palestinians I mean with the
current conflict there's already there's
already more dead Palestinians this
shows you that this we're really living
in a historical moment aren't we there's
there hasn't been this many dead
Palestinians in a short period of time
since uh arguably um 1967 or even before
yes you know in in such a short amount
of time probably even yeah even or even
before that 1948 the the actual NAA
massacr that occurred okay so um but in
response to the second in father at
dissatisfaction that Israel is not
sticking to its word into disengaging
because they never intended to disengage
and there you've probably seen that
leaked footage of Benjamin Netanyahu um
where he would talk about how to build
how to kick out Palestinians in area sea
he'd say that the agreement said that
the Israeli Army is allowed to make
military bases yes in area C uh and they
can declare any way they want in area C
according to need so Ben Netanyahu in a
in a leaked recording said that it was
actually um he he actually defined as
military areas and they could be as big
as he wanted okay and then then he can
and that was used to to further kick out
Palestinians out of the West Bank so
this is what this is what's happening
and then eventually yeah um in reaction
to the second inter father the the
Israel used this as a pretext to start
building walls enclosing area A's area a
um parts of the West Bank and in and and
uh by the way they had already begun
building settlement since
1967 and 196 7 was when uh you might say
more religious zionists got involved uh
there was an argument before that saying
that you know the you can't make a state
of Israel until the Messiah comes but
when the 196 67 War happened it was
argued that this was divine favor on
Israel and then Many religious Jews
started to support Israel and that's
when they started to be you see the
beginning of settler activity religious
religious settlers really willing to
settle into the West Bank and make
settlements there anyway so um then
you've got two more like before the the
the mowing of the lawn kind of every two
to three years you have I'm thinking
here and maybe correct me if I'm wrong
you have two more major events which is
the Lebanon war is the second Lebanon
war with heah yeah yeah so uh okay so so
basically what what we see is that um
there's there's uh called let's go to
2006 sure so 2006 2005 um the the
Israeli forces disengaged from gazah mhm
uh because they had settlement settlers
there they it was hard to protect and
disengagement doesn't mean that they no
longer have effective military control
because they control a lot of these
Israeli pundits and Zionist you know uh
people propagandists they would say well
look we're not occupying Gaza because we
disengaged in
2005 but the truth of the matter is
disengagement is not prerequisite for
non uh effective military control in
fact most of the international law
prerequisites for occupation is that if
you're control of the airspace and you
control of the sea and you control of
the population which Israel maintains
and had maintained since 2005 uh of the
entire area so they've got what it was
referred to in Natal laws effective
military control even since 2005 the
fact that they removed their the the
settlements from there could even be
said to be strategic because every 3 to
four years they're going to bomb from
the sky that would be the new strategy
wouldn't it be yeah so um uh uh
basically there's been actually sorry uh
four in involvements of Israel in B
Lebanon not three uh there was OB Al
South Lebanon war that that occurred um
I forgot to mention but there was a more
one more Reon to ask which is the 2006
level on war so in 2006 Israel does two
things um the the Palestinians of Gaza
elect Hamas via Democratic elections so
um Israel imposes a blockade over Gaza
limits their fishing limits their
getting supplies uh and so on so forth
and then invades um Lebanon in 2006
right to destroy Hezbollah it says this
is this is already after of course um
again Hezbollah responding to Israeli
attacks raids and so on so forth into
Lebanon and so there's this low-level
conflict that's that's always that
didn't stop between um the Israeli Army
and uh the Hezbollah but they said okay
we're going to destroy hisbah once and
for all so they go in and it's a
shambles they end up losing lot you know
a lot more Fighters than they
anticipated and uh they withdraw in
August 2006 so that so they've invaded
Lebanon four times uh in this in this
point in time um an army that a country
that can't strategically threaten them
it's not an existential threat at all
whatsoever uh and then the blockade of
Hamas begins and here's what you have to
understand that um Hamas is and the
Palestines of Gaza have been living
under uh conditions where their
infrastructure gets regularly bombed
under this low-level uh ceas fire or
peace agreement with the the Israelis so
um Israel has this policy um called
mowing the lawn yes right and what they
will do is they will um because Hamas is
now the government of of Gaza they have
to keep Gaza itself weak and uh and uh
well unable demoralized subdue them well
weak subdued enable to fight yeah so
they would regularly bomb infrastructure
um they would regularly bomb um uh Hamas
political targets and there are so many
we know this is recent history now there
are so many different um so operations
that have happened 3 to four years and
this is it brings me to a point which is
if you're if you've got like you know
protective Edge and castled and 2014 and
2021 and every 3 to four years you've
become predictable and you've you I mean
you're you're going against what onzo
said which is don't um you know push
your enemy when it's desperate or
something to that effect being a
desperate enemy 3 to four years they
know you're going to bond them anyway so
in many ways what you're doing is you're
creating an atmosphere for the kind of
responses that they're getting really
isn't it well you know what like um one
of the the tactics designers do when
they argue this is they say they say
well you know um like this recent uh
response by Hezbollah or they when they
fight Rockets or what have you uh we
didn't attack Hezbollah within the past
couple months or at least least exactly
well least the past month if you go if
you go back a few months you say oh
actually we did when we Bon this we took
out one target or a drone strike but
they said we didn't do it recently
within the last month but what they
trying to do is they try to separate
from the West Bank because as far as
Hamas and fat concerned these are one
Land one people so anything that Israel
does to West Bank um Hamas considers to
be done to them as well and and and
likewise the Palestines on the ground as
well and so on so um and of course
likewise the West Bank Palestinians feel
the same for the the Palestinians in
Gaza so in response to to um Israeli
clearing operations uh where they would
clear the the Temple Mount and mus AA
when they have visits by settlers or
visits by right- Wingers and and
especially those who've been implicated
in killing Palestinians what people
don't realize is see it's a Muslim
Mosque okay Muslims go to pray the
mosque it's um it's the custodians of it
are the Jordanian Authority right yeah
it's meant to be a wakf under Jordanian
Authority but it's for Muslims to use so
when when Israel or organizes a
visitation by people who are usually
right-wingers or others who do it
deliberately they have to uh first clear
out the mosque so they say right all you
Muslims going to pray uh usually uh
usually um men mostly but basically they
might keep kids with there or very old
people but they actually go with send
them their security forces to clear
everyone out Israeli Security Forces
enter the mosque to clear it all out
right so I think you've done a really
good job in summarizing the historical
points obviously the other things that
we know I mean all these operations and
many people have lived them so they'll
know about them what we wanted to do in
this episode was to give people a brief
historical timeline a skeleton that they
can go like from all these things we've
had to kind of rush it a little bit
because we've got flight to catch you
know but what I will say is is is the
following is that the the thesis or the
idea or the proposition that Israel's
been defending itself all this time
knowing full well the facts that we've
presented here is an untenable one
wouldn't you say yeah look just to kind
of summarize everything we've been
saying yes which is the Zionist project
was to create a a majority ethn
nationalist group in eth nationalistic
State yes that would represent their
ethnocultural one distinct ethnocultural
Group by a majority population so
zionists have always been concerned
about demographics they've always been
wanting to say make sure that the state
the whole land of Palestine all of it is
one is is a ethnonationalist state state
for Jews primarily yeah okay now to
achieve that there were many tactics and
strategies depending on on on the
situation at hand and they've always
been interested in expanding beyond that
some even said beyond into Jordan it's
as well as the Sinai and even into South
Lebanon yeah now historically speaking
what we've seen is a very consistent
policy from um Israel which is it's been
using Force projection in the region it
regularly invades its neighbors um even
those people that oppose uh Israel but
have ented into ceasefire agreements
Israeli peace or ceasefire looks like
lowlevel military operations yeah so uh
so basically if you say look I I
disagree with the Zionist project but
I'm going to I'm going to have peace
because I don't want my people to be
killed and I don't want to we want to be
attacked are still going to be killed
and attacked by Target operations by
raids by drone strikes by air strikes
and so which happened in Lebanon which
happens in Syria right even in Syria
right now even up to Damascus Airport
got bombed um you know uh regularly um
so this kind of happens on a low level
yes and add to the fact that if you're a
Palestinian in the West Bank um you know
the experience of living under Israeli
occupation is like being in a vat of
acid absolutely yeah you can say no one
can say well you're in a vat of AET but
who's punching you it's not the punching
that is that is the issue it's me being
slowly dissolved absolutely Yeah by um
um uh police harassment by um uh denying
building permits uh for my for your your
family and so on so forth to when you
because over the time you have children
they need to find place to live it's by
um just being shot by by police for for
the slightest uh concerns that you might
be security risk regardless of even
whether you're a child or what have you
um even just recently like the previous
month up to 20 30 palestin kids in the
West Bank have been killed yeah that's
according to un reports even right like
like like forget about you know uh uh I
think and bombings and so on so yeah so
so when you when when this is your
existence where uh you know peace with
Israel is a continual is is a continual
continually killing your people if
you're Palestinians right um You and and
not peace of Israel is you're just being
bombed and and and massacred and and
being pushed out and people say that
Israel wants to push out and take half
of Gaza now yeah um you you can see that
Israel has always been the aggressor
absolutely because it always has had the
same goal always which is a majority
ethnonationalist State on the whole land
of Palestine and currently speaking in
the whole land of Palestine there's
50/50 Palestinian Arab and and and
Israeli Jewish citizens so this is not a
demographic that designers are going to
accept and they're going to aim and
they're always going to continue to
pressure the Palestinians force them to
go eventually by continue harassment
continue bombing continue so until they
give up and they just leave so that they
can get their majority ethn nationalist
State over the whole land of Palestine
as Ben gur as they sent them right from
the very beginning which is why they
would never accept Gaza and the West
Bank as part of Israel because then
they'd have Democratic rights for those
2.2 million Palestinians in in Gaza and
however many millions 3 million or more
than that in uh in the West Bank which
would would maybe make them a majority
in fact over 50% would never give those
the West Bank and the Gaz and
Palestinians equal citizenship cuz
that's be% they have to now be between a
rock and a hard place they can't be part
of the state but they they have to be uh
attacked and the moon the the the grass
has to they have to be pressured so that
slowly over time Palestinians will leave
yes and they can get a uh and they they
always hope there' be more Jewish
migration So eventually that they can
get a majority 80% ethnonationalist
State over the whole land of Palestine
well if people have been watching this
and I thank you so much for joining me
people have been watching this is a very
brief historical timeline each and every
single one of those things that we spoke
about could have had many many
voluminous and encyclopedic chap books
and chapters written on them um from the
1800s to all the way to 1920s to 1930s
and 1967 war 1973 War we want to give
people a basic education on this and I
think in the time that we've had we've
done a very good job I thank you for
joining me I think with this honestly
with this information take it forward
and make the argument and because
remember this is an information war with
the arguments have been provided here go
and do your own research this is a basic
building block and the um if you like
the historical skeleton use it and put
your own meat on it uh because people in
the west English speaking people
especially prop Palestinian Muslim
people and others we we have a moral
obligation to keep the pressure and
change the minds of the people do it on
Twitter do it on your websites do it in
all the websites uh and using social
media this is my call to action and I
think we need to intellectually arm
ourselves and so inah um I've done a ADV
advocacy course which you can find
online I'll be doing more advocacy
Palestinian advocacy courses inah with
I3 going forward beautiful also check
out my debates with zionists uh I have
some have some debates coming up too
andd landi for those who don't know his
name put it on YouTube You'll see all
kinds of debates it's one of the most
premier and fantastic Debaters in the
Muslim modness issue in particular and
he's done many courses on this hence why
he has so much knowledge on the matter
thank you so much for joining make sure
you subscribe make sure you like make
sure you spread the message and arm
yourself with the knowledge that you
need